für den horizontalen transport auf der
erde ist der hype um eine absolut
bahnbrechende erfindung viel schneller
kommt man in der vakuumröhren von a
nach b und für deutschland gibt es
bereits erste streckenpläne aber was
ist mit dem vertikalen transport häuser
werden immer höher aber auf züge
fahren immer noch nach einem uralten
prinzip bei hohen gebäuden wenn ihre
weile tonnen schwer und drohen unter dem
eigengewicht zu reißen thyssenkrupp hat
jetzt ein revolutionäres system bundes
löst alle probleme auf einmal und
ermöglichen neue rekordhöhen von
gebäuden jetzt richtig zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
manchmal ist das leben echt verrückt in
der vorletzten nacht habe ich von einem
aufzug geträumt der komplett ungebunden
ist er kann senkrecht fahren waagerecht
er hat kein seil und weiß ich noch
geträumt habe er ist realität also ich
habe im traum geträumt dass das war ein
traum ist aber ich von etwa träume
wagnis hunter wie sondern wirklichkeit
ist und es war einer der wenigen träume
an denen ich mich nach dem aufwachen
noch erinnern konnte das allein schon
war verrückt und dann kam die meldung
und die hat sich komplett aus den
latschen kippen lassen
thyssenkrupp hat genauso ein aufzug
system gestern vorgestellt es hat genau
diese eigenschaften abseits der
öffentlichkeit wurde es entwickelt
dabei hat man sich nicht mal besonders
um geheimhaltung bemüht doch sonderlich
notiz nahm trotzdem kaum einer von dem
thema vor allem hat niemand die
dimension erkannt diese aufzug wird die
welt verändern wie der heimklub mit
dieser technologie können komplett
andere gebäude gebaut werden verfahren
die aufzüge nicht in einem vakuum wie
der hyper luft aber die werden wie der
transrapid durch magnete angetrieben das
ermöglicht ja alles die kabinen können
überall hinfahren in einem schacht
können mehrere kabine fahren und
weichen können sie quer fahren und so
weiter und so fort verfahren die
aufzüge nicht mal besonders schnell
aber durch die flexible steuerung
verringern sich die wartezeiten auf die
kabinen extrem heutzutage fallen zum
teil zurück sich prozent von
hochhäusern als fläche für aufzüge
weg weil so viele schächter eingebaut
werden müssen um den einigermaßen
schnellen transport zwischen den
stockwerken zu ermöglichen
das fällt jetzt weg für die
entwicklung hat thyssenkrupp für rund
40 millionen euro extra 1 246 meter
hohen turm in rottweil gebaut auf ihm
ist auch die höchste aussichtsplattform
deutschland höher als die auf dem
berliner fernsehturm
hier wird der multi zurzeit getestet
denn schon 2020 soll er erstmals in
berliner ist sauer eingebaut werden muss
sein wird er im rottweiler aufzug sturm
auf herz und nieren geprüft
eigens dafür wurde ein 240 tonnen beton
gewicht in der spitze platziert um den
turm in schwingungen zu versetzen und
die aufzüge unter extremen situationen
fahren zu lassen die technologie ist
dabei schon weiter
wicklung des elektromotors erprobt nur
dass sich der motor beim multi nicht
dreht sondern linear ist ein linearmotor
gerade eine schiene
wir versetzen elektromagnete keine achse
zu drehen sondern wie sitzen an der wand
und ihre magnetfelder werden nach bedarf
aktiviert so drücken wir die magnete in
einer list kabinen nach oben oder nach
unten die spacken elektromagnete haben
die kabine quasi im griff und können
wir ihn weil ich ihn fand und durch die
führung der kabine an einem
schienensystem ist es auch beim
stromausfall absolut sicher und kann
gebremst oder zum nächsten stockwerk
gefahren werden und dabei gibt es noch
einen riesigen vorteil nur bei der fahrt
nach oben wird strom verbraucht auf der
fahrt nach unten wird energie gewonnen
es wird also beim stromausfall noch
genügend energie selbst produziert um
die kabinen weiterfahren zu können das
system ist dabei so flexibel dass in
einem schacht mehrere kabinen in
verschiedene richtungen gefahren werden
können es ist die absolute zukunft und
damit fällt eine wichtige grenze weg
aus physikalischen gründen ist
heutzutage bei 600 metern schacht länge
schluss weile und kabine werden zu
schwer beim neuen world trade center in
new york bis zwölf tonnen für die
seile und zehn für die kabinen mit dem
neuen system werden im prinzip nur zwei
schächte nötig in einem wahn die
kabinen nach oben und im zeitenfahren
die kabinen nach unten wie in einem
paternoster wolkenkratzer können so
quasi unendlich hoch werden
zumindest ist sie können sehr deutlich
nach oben gewachsen es ist eine absolut
neue dimension
der flug wird diese aufzug zum game
changer für den personentransport einer
der größten herausforderung heute ich
freue mich auf jeden fall schon auf 2020
werdet sicher einer der ersten sein der
mit dem multi fährt wenn er dieses und
alle anderen neuen videos nicht
verpassen wollte dann drückt mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
dem video hyper luke bald auch in
deutschland
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt